you got to tell us what happened because
i'm curious oh we are
what's up everybody welcome to our zoom
call this is for our
high highly ranked members of our
matriarch it means you are female
you're fierce and you're at the head of
your clan or cackle you can call a hyena
clan a clan or a cackle
it's whatever you want whatever you want
to do um i
i can't wait to talk to you guys you're
valuable members of the matriarchy
we so appreciate you guys doing this we
we love doing this once a month we look
forward to it even though we haven't
done it about three and a half months
yeah i mean we're just trying to get
organized we got two screwed in
producers now the whole team
is screwed in i have a 100
clean ass what but i'm you didn't tell
me that but i'm also fully charged
you're fully charged which is great
when is the last time we did this did we
miss last month or didn't we
is the last time we did this two months
ago where did mike suarez
the last time we've done this was three
months ago yeah we have a lot of people
that we need to call so we're not
calling
everybody today but this is the first of
the two that we're going to call and
release okay
now things are on point we've got our
team assembled back together how long
has muffin chops been with us officially
now is it a month already
has been with us in spirit since the
beginning he's born to be here
yeah you and muffin chops look like
you're two sides of the same coin yeah
every time i order a blueberry muffin
now i just say just give me a mic
we're gonna come out with a muffin shop
shirt and a venna antifa shirt
on the way and i need a new home yeah
but i mean that would be funny if they
had their own shirts they should have
their own and imagine their shirts out
sell
our shirts they probably will i would
buy their shirts over our shirts if we
make a shirt for the weather girl we
will have to give her 100 of the
proceeds legally yeah
can somebody just make a shirt with the
outline of muffin chops face and we just
put the shirt muffin chops and then we
also need a vena antifa
shirt that's what we need that's what we
do which is her with like a black mask
on looking like cobra commander
and just smashing smashing the
patriarchy are we or we get
defacing a statue i'm not looking i'm
laying down again
venetia look at my gut i got a big gut
okay well venetiva let me ask you this
because you were talking about like a
guy like gianni let's say it was
not yanni i'm saying but a guy with
yanny's bod that does that's not a
turn-off for you as a woman you don't
care because he's a man
that's what that's what we were saying
before where it's like we guys get in
shape really for other guys
yeah because women don't care if you got
a little gut no they don't they just
want you to make it
huh we want someone else who can take
care of themselves so if you're going to
the gym like that's the pla
girls notice that i know you guys are
doing it for the guys but
like as long as you're a bigger guy that
can [ __ ] who cares if you don't have
six-pack abs
yeah you don't care about that yeah no
our mugs are so [ __ ] fire how fire
are people in the zoo already i mean
what are we going yeah let's go let's
start send them in because we want to go
get drunk i need to do some blow on my
blow guys come on every time we're
yeah i mean every time we're rolling now
i'm just scared that we're going to be
the kind a mike is comic-con
guys go to the 25 level if well they are
they're on the 25
level yeah everybody on the patreon oh
everybody from the 10 from the fives up
this is oh wow
this is for everybody to see but only
the 25s can talk to us
the 50s could talk to us but the 25s and
ups the 25s and ups are getting the
kamikazes now so it's a [ __ ] good
move to go to the 25s right now
because mikey muffet chops has been
filming us for weeks and we have no
known knowledge
and he make no mistake he's got a couple
of extortion clips
i mean we yeah i mean he's just
recording us at all times now 24 hours a
day so
if you think we're wild when you watch
us yeah i mean you have no idea what
happens when the mics aren't off
exactly mundo and i just yelled and my
head was turned at an angle then i blew
out one of my eardrums
it's what it is what's up guys we want
to say hello to you thank you hope
you're enjoying web on the morning
chrissy did a little blow chrissy passed
out on an episode it's been a wild week
and we still have one more episode to go
in the week tomorrow's weapon in the
morning
so we hope you're enjoying it we are
guess what guess what
guess what we're bringing back no nets
yeah i mean
who loves you more than us who loves you
baby
we're going to do a no nets episode with
jim norton aka chip chipperson
so we're going to announce we're going
to do that but baby it's going to be a
good one we're going to get [ __ ] chip
jefferson on the potty whitey
yeah no nets i've been getting a lot of
emails from the fans saying what
happened to no nets what's going on with
no nets oh wait we have
someone we have what is this we [ __ ]
had this guy wow look yeah
it looks like chris after chris got
diagnosed with aids and can't afford
viral treatment this is what is this guy
looks intersex he's a [ __ ] male on
the outside a woman on the inside this
kid looks like he could throw
hands though what can he hear us from
canada my boyfriend
look at that he matches our set
can you guys hear me notice i got stuck
that way when his brother wait we can't
hear him on
our side hold on i'm i'm not muted
you're good
we just can't hear you i'll tell you
this kid right now i know
for sure this kid is full-blown fully
charged canadian
and there's a good chance he lives in
hamilton no otherwise you would not know
who her
where are you at montreal vancouver
where is it hold on we got the volume on
the tv it's not working we're getting it
we'll get you cooking in a second now
without tv just turned off
he's off can you hear me check it out
this is talking to a guy that can't
we can't hear him he can hear us yeah i
can hear you guys
questions where you from and he can't
because he's responsible he's got
beautiful lips i'm staring right at him
look at his kid he looks like he lives
in his mother's house
i mean because this is a handsome kid
can we hear him
be here one more time say
hello can you hear me friends yeah we
can hear you very lightly
beneath will translate we're trying to
get everything worked out here
i don't live at my mother's house that's
my girlfriend's hair dryer there so
don't [ __ ] worry and i live in
bangkok
where do you live what town uh vancouver
wow cute city i had shows there and they
got kanthal
no [ __ ] i had a present to bring yanni
that you're gonna give him the tzatziki
twink shirt
[ __ ] how can you get that to me uh i
don't know maybe like a p.o box that's
uh
not uh i'll give you his home address
give me paul verzi's address and i'll
send it right to paul versi there you go
how is
how is the coven and everything in
vancouver is vancouver opened up
it's the restaurants are kind of like 50
50. but dude it's the same man just a
ton of eastern hemis that even before
kovit it was just eastern hemis and
everybody already wore masks like no
joke so
um i didn't lose my job like i'm a sheet
metal worker
like half our shop got shut and stuff
like that but other than that i'm fine i
mean i still have warts i'm still half
greek and that's all that really matters
that's right yeah and he was talking to
one person and one person only
then tia as long as the other half yeah
oh i was almost going to say as long as
the other half isn't what benedict told
me we can't talk about it
so i was just gonna just say it but i'm
learning you can't say it but if are you
yeah there's no mavericks here where we
spill benatia secrets can we do it can
we
do a venatia dating game at some point
with the patreon
would you do that i'm a girlfriend right
now no oh he's got a girl he's got a
girlfriend right now
yeah can we do a vanity a dating game or
no if we did you guys would have to go
on the date with me
oh no we wouldn't actually do the dating
game we would just see who would win for
fun
we would i mean i i appreciate how games
she is that she thought we were actually
going to take what's going on
can you kamikaze paul versi one time
maybe give him uh
give him a little uh run for his money
see what's going on
absolutely yeah yeah we're also gonna
have him on an episode
he caught paul verzi yeah he kamikaze is
odd sometimes by just [ __ ] calling me
and asked me about his gerd
i've been posting a couple of times i
want the matriarchy
to compile a clip like a [ __ ] video
clip of all of chris's fart videos
yes and we're going to cancel your
[ __ ] and make it a whole thing we'll
get jessica kirsten to [ __ ]
love it let's cancel my [ __ ] but it's
hard to get my [ __ ] because my
[ __ ] is black so
yeah fair enough you got a black [ __ ]
no black [ __ ] you do have a dark
[ __ ] right
a dark dark pigmented [ __ ] because
his smash
bean has dark pigmentation and according
to nick cannon is
superior his kid reached the haybird
time limit though unfortunately
thank you guys thank you you're the best
i love you man love you man what's his
name
thomas all soups oh this is small soup
wow the kids are [ __ ] celebrity on
the patreon
you guys uh yanni you [ __ ] sent my uh
my aunt my thea maria
cameo and that was the [ __ ] that made
the made the time man you guys are the
best
sorry chris i couldn't afford you i
already do the 50 on this thing
50 the yani on the cameo what it is yeah
what it says
um because make my cameo is a cover for
child sex race
fair enough i got [ __ ] 12 quarters
waiting for you here in vancouver when
you come next
night on the lips here we go this one's
just for you
yeah there you go thank you kid's happy
dude the kid is a man all right we got
to come on to get to the next one i'm
getting hungry
he's a real man he works with sheetrock
and we just farted a microphone and he
clapped like hercules was like
yeah his girlfriend was like what are
you is this the people you [ __ ] pay
our money for
yeah well we repeat ball soup is the man
oh here we go it's debo
wow look at this kid this kid's at a
trump 2020 rally
you're on mute
yeah we can hear you how you doing bud
good how are you guys
good what's going on yeah you know just
got home from work
[ __ ] just living every day calling in
from babe huh
boston boston are you [ __ ] what's up
kid what the [ __ ] are you doing here
guys [ __ ] boston [ __ ] over here
yeah we are on the patreon so safe at
the plate
that's safe with you so you're fully
charged that's good no
where do you live boston huh
you living with your mom no i don't live
with my mom no
okay because i wasn't sure what you're
walking into because you're wearing a
shirt it looks like it's a company that
cleans pools do you clean pools for a
living
no i do acs for a living there we go
i mean all of our matriarchy fans are
blue collar guys yeah blue collar guys
and
cuz i feel like you got a look that you
believe
kavanaugh
[Laughter]
that's the look that you got going right
now
i i appreciate it i do yeah you do i
know the kid does
he's picking a [ __ ] bud light yeah
what can you do because he's drinking a
bud light
yeah i mean he's a handsome kid he's a
good-looking kid you gotta
have married yeah i'm married with kids
oh yeah christianity was about to hit
you with the are you greek oh
no portuguese i'm a portuguese yeah
all right bubbas what um what's been
your favorite moment of the show so far
oh pearl harbor and
i love that pearl harbor uh he's like uh
you know [ __ ] a few favorite moments let
me see
[ __ ] when you guys were in your car i
[ __ ] liked that
i love that pot but my favorite's pearl
harbor
gets me through work every day so that's
a good thing [ __ ] yeah dude
good cause you got you got cauliflower
here
yes yeah i mean your kid you'll hurt
somebody that's a kid you'll [ __ ]
hurt somebody
i mean no i mean i'll grab someone and
i'll [ __ ] i'll cuddle with them
maybe that's what i'm saying a little
bit you're a kid like that
i do one of two things depending on if
i'm blow or not if i'm drunk
either i look at that cauliflower ear
and i run the other way
or i look at that cauliflower here and i
get some ranch dressing and i take a
nibble
yeah you're gonna take a nibble that's
fine with me right back there and that
when i mean ranch dressing i mean my [ __ ]
okay
that's what it is the kid the kid
deserves points for saying that he got
cauliflower ear from cuddling that's ten
out of ten
out of ten yeah it's funny yeah that's a
lot of cuddling i'm trying to get on the
floor
i'm trying to get on the force you need
to yeah because you could get once
yeah i mean you could you could possibly
join lieutenant lollipop and sergeant
snuggles
we could make you private potato yeah
what it is no you could be colonel
cauliflower colonel
yeah de-escalate
yeah i always wanted yeah you're a guy
you just come home
you [ __ ] you you ice down your
cauliflower ears and you just have a
beer you're a guy who likes a nice cold
[ __ ] beer
cause the opening day for the red sox is
coming up you excited
ah i mean the the trash the yankees got
it this year probably yeah
yeah we do yeah yeah you got a
girlfriend your wife
i have a wife yeah oh yeah kids so
how how how strict are you about the
levels of garlic
uh there's a lot of discipline that
happens in this house
i mean yeah getting disciplined by a guy
with colleagues
you don't come home from a construction
job and crack a cold beer if you're not
disciplining your wife
exactly because you didn't get the power
drill yeah
all right well bubba's thank you so much
for being a fan you've reached the
haybird time limit we love you we love
your support and
we really appreciate it man uh hey bert
hey bird
we love you bro up there in fact in
boston that guy who gets softly kissed
on the lips i mean that was a
he's one of those real guys from boston
yeah that if you go up to him and you
come to a bar and say what are you
looking at the next thing you know
yeah there's a bottle in your head and
you're choked out
he's the kind of he's a real guy he'd
probably be like yeah i could just hang
the signs up i could just do these
things
i just feel bad for whoever is gonna be
the guy that's gonna try to date his
daughter yeah cause that guy's gonna get
choked out
this guy just transitioned he's got no
facial hair now who's this kid what's
this kid's name this nick kid's name is
nanette
that's [ __ ] nanette this kid's
intersection holy [ __ ]
he's a teenager this kid his nickname is
wayfair how you doing wayfair
is this game hold on what's your name on
the patreon
uh my name on the patreon yeah
uh is that what you is that what uh yeah
you're practicing your mail voice we get
it hold on
yeah uh mikey with my
he looks exactly like you if you started
transitioning he looks like you in six
months on estrogen
yeah i do he's trying to make his voice
deeper we know that's not your voice
sounds like oh hey how are you guys
i'm a big fan on the patreon my name's
patrick mia shut up
cause you're looking are you an irish
kid
oh yeah fully irish yeah yeah cause make
no mistake i mean you got a haircut like
you play for the women's soccer team
because you look like you're protesting
for equal pay yeah
now where where are you calling in from
bubs uh virginia
near-death wow good [ __ ] red state
uh yeah uh purple state but uh oh he's a
purple state
sorry it's a little bit of both right
yeah
mixture red and blue what's what's been
what's been going on what's your
favorite moment of the podcast i mean
just tell us
something uh favorite moment
oh god this kid is i mean this kid's
high
this kid is high and like his voice is
incredible
because let me ask you a question if you
had one
shot to get a date with venetia
what would be the lines let's hear your
game what are you gonna say pitch
yourself
oh uh oh what's the one i always use
it's uh
i [ __ ] my pants can i get in yours
yeah it's
[Laughter]
you're a kid from virginia does that do
you smoke cigarettes or do you
dip you know if i want to go
true virginia style i dip but i i don't
do either
yeah how old are you i'm 25. okay you're
okay
you're 25 yeah you you say 25 but your
face definitely says 14.
yeah yeah it's just what crystal is into
that's what it is yeah yeah yeah you
look like you come
you look like you're [ __ ] i could buy
you on wayfarer
yeah you come with a cabinet because
yeah so what's going on today what are
you doing today
what are you doing today guys hi uh
about to drive out to the mountains
with the family
in virginia is it existing what's going
on there what's their policy there
we're uh we're in phase three so like
we're pretty much opened up again
uh the bars are open so people are just
getting hammered
uh people are trying to operate inside
like you go into a bar with no mask on
you have to wear a mask but you can go
inside now like fully drink have a
night saturday night in the bar uh
i think so i haven't been to it yeah you
wouldn't know because you're lying about
our age you're 16 years old
yeah i'm just way too young to go into a
bar exactly i mean
yeah your mother's going to start
yelling in the background every second
uh no i live i live with the with some
roommates here so
you know yeah i mean if you've got
roommates in virginia that's not
good oh we got hey bert patrick you got
hey birded but
bubba's thank you it's nice to finally
see you because you make the mistake you
dm me a lot and your profile picture's a
black square yeah and we
totally appreciate that instead of
having one less roommate you pay for our
patreon
yes yeah exactly
yeah it's worth it thank you bud we
appreciate it thank you
we hope you throw some hair on your dick
soon guy
i mean that kid was 14 and he would he
he talks like he's keeping a secret the
whole time yeah that's what yeah he was
oh wow
here we go here's the net this kid's
what's this thing floyd mayweather's
baby mama what is it
yeah that's [ __ ] hilarious there he
is what's up guy
oh we can't hear you put your thing on
put your put your mic on and flip your
phone
like andrew schultz says turn your phone
to the right yeah there you go bud
wow that looks like me four years ago
yeah wait he's [ __ ] cutting it out
flynn there with him
and now we got you what's up guy what's
up
boys where you calling in from i'm
calling right now from long beach island
new jersey but i'm from red hook new
york right up near uh poughkeepsie
wow wow that's [ __ ] now what do you
identify as a man or a woman
man 100 cuz [ __ ] yeah dude
so where does he say he's calling from
now long beach island new jersey lbi
he's from upstate new york poughkeepsie
he's from red hot
you said from poughkeepsie no yeah red
hook new york just about a half an hour
north of poughkeepsie
oh wow so do you know have you ever
passed any good hills where we could put
chrissy down
because the kids did blow last week
literally just come up i got all the
hills to go put chrissy down
yo he's got all the hills you ever do
blow
not yet not yet i'd love to do with you
though how old are you
23. wow we got some young fans
yeah what do you what do you do for a
living there guy
tickets for army football you sell
tickets for army football
yes i do yeah but i mean it's going to
be a tough business now
for all army sports you're a little
tough right now but uh you know
you know you'll do it what can you do
it's just what it is s low ks you got
yourself a girlfriend or a boyfriend
we're not judging
i do not have either i'm single as a
pringle venetia you hear that now let me
ask you
if you were to scoop up venetia and you
had one shot to impress her
you had one shot to pitch yourself what
would it be go ahead
let's try to win over venatia right now
i will go a thousand percent full greek
and i will suck yanny's toes
as soon as i need to
that's what it is i mean that's the best
offer you've gotten so far as a marriage
offered to vanity's gonna suck yanny's
toes
and he'll go full greek too that's what
it is he'll go he'll get he'll get the
he'll
that's what it is bubs all right well
good for you listen what's been your
favorite moment of the podcast
oh when you put when you put the eastern
hemis in the microwave
dude everywhere it's always that's gonna
come back to bite us but what can you do
i mean pearl harbor episode is
just it could be the all-time classic
and it was definitely it was untethered
chrissy before we officially got until
we should do we should do a live
watch party and watch pearl harbor
together with our fans that would be a
good one that's a good idea yeah we
should do that
when the movie theaters open back up
all right cuz you're gonna go play
soccer
[ __ ] i'm watching some [ __ ] game
right now but i was
i'm waiting for i had to talk to you
[ __ ] all right bro well let's
see you reached the hurry bear time
limit thank you for being a valuable
member of the matriarchy
if we need army
we love you man we love you
dude that's a great idea to watch like
um episodes that the fans want yeah yeah
i mean
the the pearl harbor you were i was out
of my mind by saying you were untethered
before you were officially untethered is
exactly the way to describe it oh wait
this is the ceo debenko pompoular
what's up lady
oh you're on yourself
karen unmute yourself
wait can is she unmuted yes
hi what's up girl
it looks dark where you are where are
you calling from from switzerland
wow wow switzerland wow are you an
american kid in switzerland
no i'm swedish oh my goodness what time
is it there
it is ten safety oh ten seconds oh it's
late
germans and swiss weed go well together
yeah are you gonna be my wife
did you do did you do a fush peel did
you do a for spill before this
ah yes of course with my little dog yeah
wow yeah look at how cute that is i mean
you'll get cracks
remember remember the yantilovan you're
no better than anyone else
okay that's amazing switzerland
so how is corona in switzerland right
now
um we've been deconfined since earlier
um so what does that mean deconfined um
so there's like pretty much no
restrictions left um
yeah there's no way you sound like
you're from california yeah i mean
you're not swedish
i know a girl from the oc when i hear
one okay
you're wait were you born and raised in
sweden um
i was raised in paris in france oh wait
so you're an american living in
switzerland i no no no
i just went to uh college in boston and
then i live
okay i mean this girl are you working
for russia too
no you're the one you'll never know
you're looking to my phone through my
tick tock
i'll tell you about her i infiltrated to
bring
mike mush my favorite darling bean bag
back
yeah well he's well you're good you're
gonna have to get past
yeah you're gonna have to get past uh
okay here's the deal she went to she
grew up in paris
she lives in switzerland she's swedish
she went to college in boston
she's at the 25 level means she's got
some money
we need to create an a new tier just for
her the five
thousand dollar we're gonna call it the
five thousand dollar daddy's money level
that's what it is
all those things add up to one thing and
one thing only
way oh you have no idea
she goes you have no idea yeah are you
related to gasoline maxwell
when are we going to come to switzerland
can we come to switzerland can we hang
with you and do a show out there can we
stay your chateau
switzerland or paris or sweden or
wherever you want to go
the girl scout are you single what's
your deal i'm very much single
um next flight
[Music]
one of the top ones hall of fame status
yeah i loved it so what do you do for
work in switzerland what do you do for
work
nothing um it's about to get ahold of
my dad so um what do i do for work
let me see if you work for wayfair i got
some questions to ask
no i work for the family business right
family business
which is which is daddy
what's your family business no uh we're
a full-on matriarchy
um i it's an aviation business
oh wow so you're like it's an aviation
business
what's your last name delta
yeah so we just have some planes delta
wait i think she's she's hinted to the
fact that it's mom who's
it's mom's business oh work girl you're
going to be our worker girl
yeah we're listening to weapon in the
morning
of course yeah wow she's screwed in this
she's screwed in
her family's successful and she works
for the family business in her downtime
her job sounds a lot like venetia's
where she's just on vacation but it's a
work trip
work maybe it is maybe it isn't you're a
woman a mystery
i love this girl she's great she's great
all right well listen you unfortunately
reached the harry potter timeline but
you can always message me
we love you what's your name this banco
did popularity thank goodness
one of the hall of fame all-star patreon
names
banko popular wow she's all she's a
globetrotter she's got as many houses as
champagne poppy i mean we the array
of fans i mean the guy before that whoa
what's this
holy smokes what is this who's getting
into my private photos on my phone
jake hodge this kid is ready to go i
mean this kid is
fully fully charged up we can't see his
face he's connected to the audio
because he's probably screwing his dick
back on
i mean because if you got to screw on
screw-off [ __ ]
i mean oh we lost him we lost him i'll
put him in the waiting room
oh he's not paying attention i will get
him i was about to say we just get
hunted
i was about to say we lost him man his
dad's like tell me about it yeah
i lost him oh wow here we go wow we just
went from the heiress of delta to this
[ __ ] trash monkey
what's your patreon name
he's on me unmute him
can you all hear what's your patreon
name bubbas a hunter quality
oh so that's your patreon name you you
just you you're straight to the back
i couldn't figure out how to put a name
in yeah oh could
you're a [ __ ] nice kid you're from a
southern state right
yeah yeah originally born in california
but i'm in arkansas right now working in
construction trying to get a tan so i
can survive
we are we could build a house with our
family a fan base
we could build a house and bangkok day
popular dad will pay for the materials
yeah i mean with the first four or five
members here we could really build
something and have fun smoking weed
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
can you do the kids in arkansas there's
no rules in arkansas
now let me ask you a question because
you're from arkansas the home state of
the clintons
do you think bill clinton had sex with
underage women
my favorite thing is that he took a
second to think about it he went live
let me check the evidence absolutely
yeah i love and
i have an i love a la mog do you think
these would sell well in arkansas
or no uh no
probably not let me tell you something
you got some
cute cute cute cute ceiling art what is
that behind you
well i had a bachelor party in dallas so
i'm according to quarantining with my
girlfriend right now
oh nice and your name's hunter you got a
[ __ ] nice just
name hunter it's not quilici it's
quality
quillissy yeah yeah well let's see so
cause i thought quality i thought you're
an italian kid
i am yeah i'm a sauce monkey oh you are
sauce monkey
you gotta see you're just down to earth
what's been your favorite moment of the
podcast
uh uh every time you say something
and then giannis has to check his bang
to see if he can afford money next week
[Laughter]
yeah now at what point are we expected
to hear your
girlfriend scream from the background
are you talking to those two [ __ ]
idiots that you pay to listen to
uh no she just left for work thankfully
perfect time perfect timing yeah
we'll see if yeah that's good now what
does she do
she serves yeah yeah she serves
yeah what the garlic yeah yeah yeah
or else you look like you got a nice
ceiling too you look like you got is
that a chandelier
it's his girlfriend's apartment oh it's
his apartment oh it's like she's got
like a thing hunter looks like a big
yamaka yeah it looks like a big like
bandana or something now she surfs for a
living she goes to the water and surfs
no no no no no no no she she serves oh
she serves oh she
oh so she's got a mask and gloves on and
she's ready to social distance and hand
people cocktails
i was gonna say arkansas is open now
right like what's the rules of corona
with arkansas i mean because
arkansas is already socially distanced
because there's only like 14 people in
the whole [ __ ] state
is that true yeah yeah there's like 12
of us so we just kind of
yell at each other from a distance so we
don't really are restaurants with all
that open
yeah yeah for the most part they're uh
you guys don't give a [ __ ]
no no no we don't you think dr fauci's
making it all up
easily he's a liar too
you move you moved you moved on your own
will from california to arkansas no
no your witness protection yeah what are
you doing in arkansas guy from
california that's what i want to know
uh family family grandma got all sick so
we all moved down here to take care of
her
didn't help very nice and then you
developed the southern accent when you
got there
yeah slowly been here seven years a
little fun you're a sneaky little
[ __ ] guy
because i bet you like a year ago you
were like what's up dude yeah man i'm
[ __ ] california as hell
and then you move down there you met
your girlfriend you're like she's a
piece and you walked up you were like
howdy ma'am
how you doing my name's hunter
hunter that kid's got a ponytail oh hey
burt alright we got hey birded thank you
so much for being uh
a valuable member of the matriarchy we
really do appreciate it
of course thank y'all thank you i thank
you what's his patreon name
hunter kulichi hunter kulichi i mean the
kids got an italian last name
us i i swear to god our guys are they're
all working class guys i cannot believe
he went from ceo here he is wow
wow the kids got a bloody nose i mean
what happened what happened to you guy
i mean we the kid put a pepper up his
nose for the zoom call
he's got a bloody nose what's going on
did you do some blow this weekend
yeah i mean he's got a bloody nose you
know it's probably just dry
air in the house or he was with chrissy
and montauk this weekend yeah what's up
guy i remember you from friday night and
when i blacked out
did you give my baby's mama my phone
you don't have an audio interface we got
to get you to rejoin
you got to rejoin because we can't hear
you i mean this kid's wild he's
connected to the audio now i mean he's
wild he's got a bloody nose and he's
taking a call from
us i mean this kid is [ __ ] wild
jake i'm muted
you can hear me yes what's going on guys
well no no no no what's going on with
you what's going on with you you got a
bloody nose
i'm kind of like one of those uh anime
girls
when i uh see two hot guys blood just
gushes out
because i'm all in i was doing a little
blowing mom talk last week and i guess
you were too
do you have a hot pepper up your nose uh
[ __ ] paper towel did your nose really
start bleeding
like when the call started yeah i
messaged uh
uh v uh saying uh hit me up later
and it just never stopped why is your
nose bleeding
i have no [ __ ] clue oh why is the sky
blue
yeah it's uh he's probably it's probably
very dry air
is it dry air you think kids jack though
look at that gets jacked
no i'm not jacked this is uh fat muscle
yeah where are you calling from because
are you where are you calling from
getting pa
ready wow so shocked that you guys did a
video on reading pa
yeah yeah because it's a real [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah i mean reading the kind of town
your nose just starts bleeding
[Music]
yeah dude for no [ __ ] reason bro
you're [ __ ] what made you guys do a
video on redding
because i did a uh i did a um a private
show there uh at the at the uh what's
that hotel there
the nice one now they've got a nice one
down there it's kind of in a bad
area but it's a new hotel abraham
lincoln hotel
i don't [ __ ] know i can't remember to
be honest with you and then i started
googling redding and i
realized it had one of the it had a very
fascinating history
yeah i used to yeah i used to i mean now
it's just you and your bloody nose
and a couple of crackheads walking are
you in the basement where are you are
you a hostage
no well i might be i don't know what's
coming out of the ceiling got holes in
the ceiling
i don't got holes i got one [ __ ] hole
in the ceiling i'm a big deal
[ __ ] uh maintenance person i got one
hole in the ceiling my
i got one nostrils bleeding go [ __ ]
yourself
that's what i'm saying bro what's uh
what's your patreon name guys
jake hodge but i didn't know how to
change it so when i was putting my name
in like an idiot i put my name in
you can go back and change it if you
want to i haven't figured that out yet
well jake what what do you do for work
oh i used to build batteries now i just
started my own tech company
it's called havoc build batteries it's
nice
so if the matriarchy wants to keep me
off the street keep me uh
away from tootin they can uh go support
where is it what's what's the place tell
everybody
uh basically we do custom pc builds
no what's the website oh havoc tech
llc.com you don't even know your own
website i mean you're
there it is look at that right boom
havoc tech llc.com
he'll help you with your pc and he'll
clean out your porn history
and customers everything shout out doug
richardson
shout out doug richton all right brother
we're gonna let you go uh
seek medical attention
[Music]
all right guys thank you later bro we
love you man thank you what a bunch of
wild [ __ ] idiots we have i mean this
kid called with a bloody nose
i mean it happens when he was like i
don't know what happened i'll tell you
what happened
it's called cocaine this is wow
this kid's on blow too yeah now you're
calling from your truck
you're right i'm gonna unmute it
underneath it can you hear me
yeah i can hear you dude it's the boys
what's up guy you look like you're on
the run somewhere i'm a truck driver i'm
working right now but i'm pulled over
nice dude you're pulling over to get
some road head no
[ __ ] i wish chris some [ __ ] lot
lizards
wait what state are you listening listen
listen i gotta say something me and
chrissy got a lot in common all right we
both got big square heads
fat asses and we both got skull [ __ ]
by an older boy when we were young
what it is welcome yeah yeah the only
people the only two people on the planet
i could share with their youtube boys so
i had yeah
yeah well you didn't just share with us
you just showed shared it with about 3
000
people well follow me on instagram if
you want no
what's your snapchat riley
where are you calling from uh fort
mcmurray alberta northern canada
oh canada let me tell you boys let me
tell you something
right wing capital of the planet and i'm
liberal cut kids so i'm
behind enemy lines right now there you
go you're undercover you got a pepper
yeah you see yeah when when uh when a
liberal kid goes undercover he takes his
glasses off
right when a conservative kid goes
undercover he puts his glasses on
all you gotta do all you gotta do is
turn the hat like this
and then throw the shades on and i look
like every every millennial on facebook
making a racist comment
there you go you fit right in and then
you take the hat off and it's in the net
yeah it's just right back yeah
cuz what's been your favorite moment of
the potty wadi so far
oh easily frank rizzo that man is on the
episode good episode another great
episode yeah
all that all that male aggression makes
you a little stiff
yeah have you been enjoying weapon in
the morning love it
love it i wake up i wake up at 3 30 in
the morning so when that hits in the
morning perfect
yeah i mean if you wake up at 3 30 it
means you've had a full day oh no it's a
different time in vancouver
he's in vancouver where are you oh
alberto mcmurray that's uh northern
alberta
oh northern alberta where's is that
what's the time zone
uh i think it's he doesn't [ __ ] what
time is it right now
how many kids drive the truck three
o'clock three o'clock
okay yeah so two hours two hours behind
us now if you had one shot to date
venatia
how would you win her over
i'd probably fart in a bag and mail it
to her
[Music]
that's what it is this kid's a wild kid
i mean he's definitely got molested
energy
yeah cuz it's what it is i mean yeah all
right bubba's well thank you so much we
really appreciate all your support
oh perfect thank you boys we love you
uh we i love you i love you too many
times all right man i'll see you at the
meetings
i mean we got to figure out this echo
thing we will eventually right yeah
all right his kids ready to [ __ ] go
uh this kid now this kid spends way too
much time on the internet
yeah this kid's got that look that he's
got 14 fake accounts on reddit
who's on your shirt is that giannis on
your shirt
you got to unmute
oh there i was like [ __ ] debo for a
minute sorry here it is
what's your patreon name uh you didn't
read it out loud so i want you to read
it
uh hold on i'll read it for you give me
one second
you bitched out wow
let's read it let's read it you bitched
out of reading my patreon name live one
time
darren darion marisa what is it
maurice is a character piece of the
situation oh that's right because i was
right next to her when i was reading it
right you couldn't do it
on the live stream but you know what now
we're clear now we're [ __ ] home free
yeah i mean that you deserve more you
deserve more from christy d out of that
one that's a great name
great great great i don't blame you you
would have caught a sandal
where are you calling in from vancouver
bc
wow we got a lot of canadian fans we got
a lot of connections we got a lot of
true does
a lot of those a lot of everything what
do you do for work
uh i do construction commercial sheet
metal i mean we could build a whole
village with
a lot of sheet metal guys
we got so many sheet metal guys we're
gonna have to draft which ones make the
team
yeah a bunch of scumbags that's what we
are have you ever been to new york
no i would love to i'm a huge yankee fan
really
yeah how did that happen behind me oh
yeah
oh are those is that your drum set
behind you too
yeah there's drums there yeah that's
what it is dude what it is i mean
because you need some art on the walls i
mean the walls are
pretty bland no it's it's five
millimeters in two months you have a
girlfriend
or you just made your monkey with your
own hand
no i do both come on you have a
girlfriend yeah
i do a little bit of my girlfriend yeah
that's a [ __ ] very very nice dude
that just looks like you're put together
you're a well-kept guy
you guys live together or no yeah we do
yeah okay now do you have your own room
and she has her own room because
no i'm not you and your wife giannis
that's a good one wow
yeah wow we're old-fashioned we're
hasidic jews
you have sex wants to procreate through
the sheet the beds only get pushed
together once a month
you have sex through the sheet metal
yeah exactly just got a little hole in
it
because you're good on the drums uh no i
want to bang something out real quick
you want to bake something i do not no i
do not huh you got red hair
you're red-headed no i don't i have
blonde hair i have a red beard
i'm a lego monkey nordic kid yeah a lego
monkey i'm from denmark
a lego monkey's hand this kid [ __ ]
brings the heat yeah i mean this kid's
bringing the heat he's coming in 10 out
of 10.
what's been your favorite moment of the
podcast oh
[ __ ] i don't know man i've been
listening to you guys for so long
good for you dude and you're enjoying
the patreon content everything you're
putting out there you like it
100 you guys i've been listening to you
guys for so long you've changed my
speech pattern when i talk to people
good yeah yeah
yeah it's a mental illness that you now
have i feel like i'm a [ __ ]
firefighter
when the world when the world opens back
up we're going to come out to vancouver
and do a show
yeah yeah i know you were supposed to
come out here already all right
but it got moved to november so
hopefully it's open oh i know i still
have tickets for it don't worry
[ __ ] yeah dude right at the end of your
show if you don't think i'm going to
stand up pull my pants down pull up the
lap quest and throw three loonies on the
stage you got another thing coming
you're not a three dollar bill you're
three loonies i'm three loonies bud
three looty bill all right thanks
brother you wanna [ __ ]
you gotta work on that that needs a
little work johnny yeah [ __ ] gorbad
i'm from canada yeah you wanna [ __ ]
how many more
yeah i mean we're running out of steam
we want pizza no manatees said no
it's she does say yes to marge it's so
[ __ ] hot in here
oh god two more tilland's this is dylan
straight to the back
wow it's chris the teacher in disguise
oh you got to unmute yourself i mean
this kid
is great he's got shirts he's got baby
gorgeous he's got the ladder 14.
what's up dylan just you got to unmute
yourself
is he calling in from a wheelchair you
gotta mute yourself bud
i can't hear you still what does he
gotta do just press unmute
on your box you got it hey yeah here's
one thing i know about you 100
it is not easy for you to get through
airport security
[Music]
oh there you go kid was in disguise too
you went just wow you're not you came in
as an undercover muzzy you came as an
undercover democratic muzzy
what's going on where you calling in
from uh pennsylvania uh bucks county
it's like 45 minutes above
philly now are these are these are these
the creams you jerk off with what's off
to the side here
it's all my equipment ball equipment
oh he's got oh he manscaped he's got uh
wow did you use the hyenas promo code
for that manscape of course of course
[ __ ] yeah dude now because
when you shave your balls down do you do
your head first or afterwards
he's got tested butt cream
do you use the manscape to do the head
and balls together
i mean i've just been buzzing i mean
come on listen to joe rogan so
yeah do eventually you just start
cutting your hair short it's just it
just happens yeah
[ __ ] buzz it's like whatever and just
this thing it really is
now your mother's your mother's room is
it across the hall or is it upstairs
what your mother's your mom's room yeah
it's downstairs yeah
all these people like no no no no you're
asking everybody
i'm just waiting here for my turn like
yeah [ __ ] yeah dude because i didn't
follow a word he just said what's he
talking about i don't know
what what do you do for work i was a
line cook
um but not right now yeah cause you got
caught putting boogers in the food
no now the whole kobe thing a lot of
play most places are still clear
you were a line cook i did a line of
coke what's the difference
everything is floating still you ever
done blow
no not really just yeah have you ever
have you ever been on the show to catch
a predator because you look familiar
familiar because i uh i cam dylan morris
i came up with the tier the dylan mars
tear it made giannis mad the one time
i was like that's a great tear dude [ __ ]
what's your name dylan morris they
called the [ __ ] dylan morris tear
fight i was like job i'm sorry you're
the man dude
no you're the man are you circumcising
me it was crazy
you've been around for a while we
appreciate you brother yeah
is your beef snipped or no it is
it is it wasn't let me ask you we're
gonna ask you people
if you have a chance to get a date with
venetia what would be your pickup line
i i got a i got a sticker i actually got
it from my mom but
this would be my proud democrat
that's the best one that's yeah that's
what it'd be coming with proud democrats
you're in
venetia is nodding yes i think that if
we had a dating game you would win
that's all you need to do if i wanted to
hook up with one of you guys i'd whip
out this probably
there you go absolutely guys
yeah you just made chrissy's [ __ ] wet
yeah
i'm leaking oh man oh hey bird you got
the hate burger you got the
unfortunately we appreciate you and
thank you for buying those shirts and
thank you for being a commercial
for those shirts ladder 14 and amy gore
jobs
favorite thank you bro see ya
peace one more last one
good yeah it was fun spin the
oh oh boy it's the truffle pit
burger because i want some beer i want
some [ __ ] beer
i mean right now we're looking at this
kid's balcony he's [ __ ] fractured
beats yeah i mean the kids on his
balcony making beer i mean there he is
jesse the truffle pig
i'm you baby mute yourself hey babes
what's up there you guys drop a pig we
got the weishan chia shirt on your hairs
grow long you look like a natural woman
i'm comfy lumpy babes where's
your balcony where do you live i live in
crown heights
dude that's a [ __ ] nice balcony yeah
yeah you guys ready to get peeling check
this out
let's see it my feet and oh
wow yeah look at how cute those are
because you put a hammock out on your
balcony
yeah it's like a it's a camping hammock
yeah you know it's funny
he lives in crown heights which when i
was growing up was pretty much
all black on one side all jewish on the
other side when the truffle pick moved
in dad said they knew that the
neighborhood had changed there's a white
dude with a hammock on his balcony
is there anything more white than
putting a hammock on your balcony in
crown heights
babes i moved here in 2006. so
oh wow you've been there for years can
you show us
the uh the bathtub where you make the
beers for us
i can show you my brewing equipment but
it's not in the bathtub babes
jess let me ask you this have you been
hanging out with members of the
matriarchy during corona
nah i was laying low until i got called
back to work i just started working at
the brewery
uh about a month ago so you were home
you were pretty much in that crown
heights apartment since march
yeah until uh june 22nd
did you not step outside your house once
he lives in crown heights he was like
you know what i'm just going to stay in
the hammock for a little while till
things cool down here i got a hammock
you know yeah just hang out here got
beer i got the hammock
who do you live with i live by myself
babe you want to come over coming over
son
i mean how great is jesse the truffle
pig he's number one he's a [ __ ]
legendary og fan
yeah check this out guys the first thing
i did when i started working at the
brewery
was can this yes
peach yes peach
[Music]
all right can you send uh send us a
bunch of beer we'll give you venetia's
address just send it there
you got it no jessie truffle pig is
great because him and a
few other members of the matriarchy like
they became friends after some of our
shows and like stayed in touch and hung
out
absolutely you guys talk still on
instagram
just a little bit mostly on ig i'm in it
for the content i'm a busy kid you know
did you crack open any members of the
matriarchy
all right truffle pig listen we gotta go
because we got one more and we and we
we're i did blow this weekend so i i
need to go score some drugs
okay babes uh great talking to you thank
you trouble's the best we'll talk to you
soon truffle pig it's the great truffle
pig
one of the one of the hall of fame
patreon members
everybody knows the truffle picked jesse
the truffle pig the kid makes brews we
didn't drink them
because venetia said they could be
poison yeah so
you thought there were little
microphones in there that they would be
listening to or talk yeah
wow wow wow wow it looks like my turkish
cousin is here here we go
yeah this guy's camera's bouncing i mean
this guy got jesse the truffle pig
wait a second we have been we've been uh
we've been hijacked right here
uh we have a statement from isis go
ahead let us know what you're here we go
let us know what your terms are we're
about to get a live beheading here on
the patreon
we've been hacked yeah
can you guys hear me yeah we can hear
you guys how you doing okay
you guys want to watch me ride the
pedals on here hell yeah dude
where are you calling in from san jose
california
if you got a peloton you got some money
yeah right except people use it who do
you live with
i live with my wife which does use it
yeah dude when is the last time does
your wife
when she goes outside is she head to toe
like full just the eyes out
[Laughter]
actually my my wife's greek actually
i got one here's the thing her father
was not happy
what nationality are you i'm iranian
nice i'm [ __ ] american dude that's
what i am
i love all right we give you credit for
calling it
iranian and not persian it's the same
thing
that's right how was that conversation
with your wife's father
your
oh that's easy that's why it was able to
happen listen
that is the advice you need if you want
to win the heart of a greek girl you got
to wait for her father to be dead to get
in there
yeah yeah so yeah anybody out there
wants vanity a killer dad
because what do you do out there in san
jose heck the kids attack tech
oh how'd you guys know yeah i just
[ __ ] know
you got a peloton you got a greek wife
you're [ __ ] middle eastern sandy
and you're in san jose guys
or [ __ ] strawberries
[Laughter]
no you're right it's tech it's good for
you dude it's booming right now right
yeah um in the field i'm in ai and [ __ ]
there's a lot of stuff going on a lot of
kids in a.i yeah you're not so what
what's a nice [ __ ]
what's the future going to look like how
soon is ai going to just take over
should we have voted for andrew yang i
like the guy
i think he's got some fun ideas that's
for sure until i liked him
what kind of ai do you work on so i work
on the hardware side so i'm just trying
to
build like super efficient um
processors for ai so like you know you
buy
intel cpu it's a general processor can
run
word on it can run a browser on it it
can run whatever i mean
this kit turned it into a business zoom
called
[Laughter]
let's do it let's do it are you guys
serious yes
absolutely we'll see if we'll see if the
patreon members will fund it
oh yeah right let's see no if you guys
want me to you just gotta let me
um share the screen that's all oh oh
yeah we don't we can't do it
you will get funding because you're
screwed in kid you got a greek wife
and i know because i'm greek and vanity
is greek if you don't get the funding
her family does have money hidden in the
mattress that you can get
right i feel like i feel like you work
for tech during the day and then at
night you moonlight editing for isis
execution videos
they send them over to you and you just
[ __ ] put a song behind them you put
the subtitles on
actually we're christians oh wow
like that's supposed to make me trust
you
i don't believe in god i'll tell you
like i tell you straight up i knew he
was christian because
father dead or alive if you're a greek
girl the relatives in the extended
family are not going gonna let a
non-christian
marry a greek girl yeah that's one way
to wake the dead is by having a greek
dad [ __ ] find that his wife married a
buzzy
but actually chris she's a physical
therapist she is
yeah well dpt doctor of physical therapy
yeah it's [ __ ] great dude you got it
you guys you got a great life do you
have kids
no live in it dude your friend right now
you free free as a bird
where did you uh where'd you go to
college you seemed like a smart kid
uc davis yeah
dude i mean what is up with our fan base
i mean we have the most brilliant kids
who are in tech and we go all the way to
barely sliding into human like
play at the plate like you got to do a
review at the plate and say yes he's
human
that's great though hey you guys got to
take that weapon in the morning make it
a little bit later
because it's six in the morning for us
on the west coast i know
we've been thinking about that but we
just don't know really like what's the
time to do it yeah
like ten well you can only you know you
can watch it whenever you want when you
wake up
i know yeah i know but you know how long
have you been on the patreon
since the beginning dude and you know
fifty dollars a month it made nothing i
mean the kid's a tech genius
yeah it's not the little 50 bones so
you're trying to get
you're trying to get funding for your
company plug your company right now
what's your company
it's called ariano um it's a
it's like i said it's ai hardware
startup and we're focusing on building
stuff
that's for like super low power
applications
nice too much but that's called ariana
ariana like ariana grande sounds like a
cabbage from wayfair
this guy's a great guy this guy's a
great guy i would i feel safer with him
than the rest of the animals we just
spoke to
me too absolutely when we come to san
francisco as close we get to san jose
well i want to give you free tickets
that's how much i
[ __ ] just love your energy [ __ ] yeah
no i'll pay for it anyways but i'm going
to bring everybody
dude and be honest i caught you
you honest i caught you when you were at
uh what is that woman sonny
cobbs
yeah did i did i fight anyone or was it
was it a decent show no you're [ __ ]
sick and you were just like you kept
asking the uh the lady is like all right
how much longer
all right wow he almost passes out every
show
was that when i was always passing out
no no this was uh
actually it was the night of the
mcgregor fight with uh what's his name
the other guy
i remember that i was sick it was
mcgregor versus
uh was that mcgregor mayweather yeah
that's it oh that sucks
yeah so i was just trying to get off
stage because i wanted to watch the
fight
yeah no we can watch you watch the fight
it's very interesting
comedy club yeah let me ask you this
when we come when we come
to that to the to the valley again
um does your wife cook good cookies or
do we should we bring yaya's cookies
uh yeah maybe i asked cookies
see your wife doesn't cook a greek food
um
i mean she does the baklava and stuff
like that yeah but that takes doesn't
[ __ ] allow that he's
kidding me he doesn't allow that fidel
food he's like only here we have a shish
kebab and a bubblegum
that's what it is yeah oh my god yeah no
this guy's got to he's going to honor
kill one of his kids this kid's
he says we have my kids only hummus
i can't wait yeah oh we got hey birded
um
so thank you so much for being a value
member of the matriarchy brother we
really do appreciate it especially
all the way from the beginning man thank
you for your continued support
thank you for uh you guys for all that
entertainment man it really does come
through
thank you brother we appreciate it thank
you for your service
i mean we got great fans we love that
guy was great i like we ended on [ __ ]
that guy was fantastic yeah kick that ac
on please
are we done yeah oh we're going to say
goodbye goodbye yeah thank you to
everyone for me seriously and
thank you for me we really appreciate
everyone uh for the support i mean
you don't know how much this means to us
and i really have a good time putting
faces to some of the names that we
constantly see
so thank you thank you thank you so much
and yeah i mean a lot we you know if
anybody wants to make us a sign at a
sheet metal
go ahead yeah i mean we got plenty of
options if anyone wants to build us a
bridge we know who to call
let's do it peace out guys we'll see you
next time thank you